les frais de restockage quel est le
rapport entre ces frais est la loi de la
jungle les frais de restockage d'abord
si vous retournez un produit pas parce
qu'il est défectueux juste parce qu'il
ne vous convient pas de plus en plus de
détails en exigent des frais depuis la
pandémie tout coûte plus cher aux
détaillants matières premières coûts de
production employés mais les
consommateurs aussi sont préoccupés par
les prix alors les détaillants font
attention à ne pas les augmenter leur
truc ils coupent dans le service prend
donc dans les retours sans frais
auxquels on est si attaché la loi de la
jungle maintenant l'expert en marketing
jacques nantel nous rappelle que la
nature est sans pitié les plus faibles
vont fermer leurs portes ou se feront
avalés par les plus gros il y aura donc
moins de concurrence et les plus gros
vont progressivement augmenté leurs prix
après ils laisseront tomber les frais de
stockage peut-être en attendant
rappelez-vous le détaillant qui reprend
un produit pour vous offrir un service
c'est un peu comme une espèce menacée
alors renseignez vous avant d'acheter ac
le monde
[Musique]